>> So, hello everyone.
My name is Dhrubojyoti.
I'm a PhD student working with
Professor Anish Arora at
Ohio State University.
Before we tell you about
what we explored as
part of this workshop,
I would like to give
you an overview
of the problem that we
were interested in.
So, we have traditionally done
shallow machine learning on
mote scale and slightly larger,
maybe ASOC scale devices.
One of the devices that
we have developed is
a 50 milliwatt Pulsed
Doppler Radar that
is integrated with
a 64 megahertz Cortex M3 mote,
this is what we call the
bumblebee radar and a.NOW Board.
When an object displaces
in front of the radar,
even though it cannot
do absolute ranging,
what it can do is
it can figure out
the displacement of
the object and create what
we call a cut for the duration of
the object's displacement
that is visible by the radar.
Through analysis of the cuts,
we have traditionally designed
some engineered features
in amplitude phase
and joint time-frequency domain
over the duration over
the displacement.
For detection of
objects such as humans,
cows, cars, et cetera,
we have traditionally relied
on an RBF-kernel SVM using
12 features down selected from
a bigger list of
90 or 100 features.
It currently has 94.6 percent
accuracy for
object classification.
However, it comes with
the huge overhead of A,
storing the support vectors which
alone consumes 30 kilobytes.
B, feature computation in fact
consumes more than 90 percent
of the end-to-end
classification cycle.
So if the classifier
is- we cannot really,
our features are
such that we need
a substantial length
of the cut to
be processed in order to generate
them because they are
statistics built on time.
Therefore, 90 percent or more
of the full classification cycle
is consumed by
feature computation.
So, these are essentially
the two tall poles and we
were really motivated to try
out feature learning
techniques instead of
feature engineering techniques to
see if we can mitigate them.
Before coming here, we did
experiments with Bonsai,
we found that it gave us
95.2 percent accuracy.
It only consume two kilobytes
of memory which was
a big win in terms of
the classifier size,
but the caveat was
still that we had
to compute engineering features.
The second application we are
interested in along
with our partners at
New York University is deploying
a sensor network comprised of
the nodes that you see here.
They are slightly bigger than
the mote I showed you
in the previous slide.
These are more like
variable scale but not quite.
The devices are custom
built for this project.
They have an application
processing unit,
a microprocessor,
and a microcontroller in
decreasing order of power.
There's a one megabyte
on-chip RAM.
The objective of
this project is to
classify noise complaints in
New York City in real-time so
that real-time actuation
can be done on them.
Because a city,
an urban canyon is
highly variable and
dynamic environment
and the noise conditions,
the background conditions,
the noise intensity,
et cetera are all
extremely variable based on
where you place the devices.
None of the existing
smaller datasets
of non-speech sounds were
really enough to train it,
which is why a cut was
built from the Google dataset
to train what we call the Look,
Listen, and Learn
audio embedding that
came out from Google last year.
So here, what we do is we
train an audio sub-network and
a video sub-network together
and learn the association
between them,
are they related or not?
For example, this is
an audio clip from a guitar
and this is a picture
of a guitar,
are they related or not?
The advantage is that
there is no need
for explicit labeling.
Something that we lack in
huge quantities of sound
data that we've collected,
but we're also
implicitly grouping
similar audios together and
finally we cut out
this audio sub-network,
apply it to some smaller
downstream datasets
such as DCASE or
the Urban Sound and use
that as an embedding with
us more MLP classifier.
Yeah, here the tall poles are
that the embedding alone,
the audio embedding alone
is 56 megabytes,
it's pretty huge.
It can never fit onto
the 500 kilobyte budget
that we have on
these devices which
is why we were
motivated to try
several techniques to
see how we could shrink them.
So in pursuing these
two directions,
we have designed
a few experiments
in the workshop that we
wanted to explore and
get results from so that they
would set the foundation
for the next steps
in our research.
So, Pranshu would
next speak about
the experiments in
the radar domain
which involves RNNs. Thank you.
>> Hey everyone. So basically,
the thing was that as
Dhrub pointed out,
our objective was to try
out the RNN on the human,
non-human dataset to
see whether we can
get a competitive accuracy
while getting
rid off the cost of
feasible competition which
was present there in
SVM Bonsai technique.
So the thing is the way that
RNN concept works is that
let's just say that you have
a certain batch on
which your training,
the RNN, it's supposed to
roll over to a fixed number
of time steps.
The caveat here is
that all our cuts,
they obviously are different.
One is of two seconds,
one is of five seconds,
one is of 10 seconds,
and so on so forth.
So, one way to tackle
with this problem
was that instead of training
directly on the cuts,
you actually artificially
create,a training dataset
by taking windows out of
the cut with
an appropriate stride,
create both a training
and a testing dataset,
train on the training dataset,
classify on the testing dataset.
For getting the accuracy
on a test cut.
Basically, for all the
windows which had been
created for this test cut.
Do something like
majority prediction.
So, when we tried
out this approach,
the problem was that for
the test cuts which had
relatively shorter length of
two seconds or even lower,
the accuracy was relatively poor.
So, we are only able to reach
an accuracy of
roughly round about
94.8 percent only on the cuts
which were greater than-
>> Clarify, what you're cutting?
>> Basically, a cut, a data file.
>> So, how is this related
to previous two slides,
which applications
are you looking at?
Are you looking at
a specific application?
>> So this is related to
the radar application.
When an object displaces
in front of the radar,
we have a displacement detector
that cuts out the section
of the ambient that
corresponds to the
displacement of the object.
We refer to that as a cut.
Sorry for not clarifying this.
>> So basically, as I mentioned,
the problem with
this approach was that
those tests cuts
for short duration,
the accuracy on them
was relatively poor.
Yeah. So basically, we
tried out a second approach
of dynamic RNN,
which had the
flexibility that even
if the cuts were
of varying length,
in the training dataset,
it would unroll to the number of
times of any specific cut.
Here the first risk was that,
on the test cut, if you
take the longest length,
it was exorbitantly
long, of one RNN.
It's very difficult to train
as you increase
the number of time steps.
So what we did was we took
a sub-cut length from each cut,
and we had this thing
that in case if
a cut does not have the length
equal to sub-cut length,
just simply part it to
become equal to that.
Now, train directly on
the cuts rather than
any artificial dataset
and classify
directly also on
the test cuts themselves.
This was giving
pretty comparative accuracy
of 96.5 percent.
Also, we remove that restriction
that the test cuts,
they have to be greater than a
certain length like 2.5 seconds.
This is for all the
possible test cuts.
So, I've mentioned some
of the figures here.
So, that the model size,
it's reasonably comparative
if you compare,
especially with the
SVM of 5.7 KB in
comparison to 30 KB is
larger than the Bonsai,
but, the thing is that,
we've gotten rid of
the future that
competition thing.
So, this is a pretty good result
because this
illustrates that term,
without resorting to
more complicated techniques
like dual RNN and by
avoiding future competition,
we can get a good accuracy
with relatively low model size.
So, these are some of
the advantages as I
mentioned that only fix sub-cut
of approximately two
seconds is required.
This makes way for
faster classification,
no stacking this thing, to
verify this more efficient.
So, extending this
sorting further,
Android data set
which is patently
a harder task than
the human versus nonhuman.
We tried out you can see
a number of techniques,
like you can say SVM, Bonsai,
DeepBonsai and this thing,
and irrespective of
the technique used,
it's giving an accuracy
of you can say,
roughly 80 percent.
So, the one good thing which
will illustrate [inaudible]
is roughly you can
say competitive
as compared to other techniques
on the android data set.
But the larger implication was
that there's a shortage of
data in this particular task
and we need more data.
The possessor of that data
collection is continuing on,
and I am hopeful that
in the next 1-2 months,
we get an access and make
better inroads into so exercise.
>> We have a C-sharp
implementation of the RNN,
which is what our motor runs on.
So, it uses a paired
down version of
Microsoft.net micro framework
that we call the e-mode,
but the application programmer
writes code in C-sharp.
We could not demonstrate
for you today,
and we apologize because we do
not have the hardware
board with us,
it did not reach us in time.
But it is developed
fully unit tested,
and we can start doing
field tests as soon as we
get back from this workshop.
>> Shriram, this is
the paper we've submitted
to NIPS this time,
and they don't a focus
on the classifiers so
there's no proton in Bonsai,
but there's a completely
new architecture for doing
feature computation
and time series.
>> Sorry, how much
time do we have?
>> Thirty more minutes.
>> Okay. Yeah, I'll
be slightly fast.
So, now we go to
the sonic project of
tackling noise complaints
in New York City.
So, to remind you
of the motivation,
we have to fit the system at
a relatively big classifier,
the L3 embedding onto
a 500 kilobyte budget.
So, we took two directions
to explore this question.
One was, can RNNs
work out-of-the-box to
tackle the problem?
Do we even need an embedding for
a non speech acoustic events?
So, we tried extensively with
single-layered or
stacked GRUs and LSTMs,
and some variants
such as FastGRNN,
and we used the
UrbanSound 8K data set,
which had around 200,000
training samples.
These are some of the
hyper-parameters we played with,
and some of the model
variance we played with.
So, in the first
phase, we compute
a Mel-spectrogram
of 199 timesteps
across 256 filter bands.
This is used as input to the RNN.
We optionally have
a second layer of RNN,
if we looked into stacking,
and finally, we have
10 output classes.
So, we tried various
hidden dimensions
dropout rates, learning
rates et cetera,
and a few variants
of RNNs such as,
low-rank FastGRNNs
and stacked RNNs.
So, we observe that
the main issue with
RNNs in tackling
non-physical events is
that they suffer from
severe over fitting,
and no matter what we
did we couldn't bridge
the train test gap
closer than 30 percent.
For example, this is some of
the best results
we got using RNNs,
92 percent accuracy in 60 epochs,
and by this time,
the training saturates, so we
didn't really continue further.
But the validation accuracy
is like 63 percent,
even though the model says
that's sufficiently small,
if it would have worked,
it would have been great
for us, but it didn't.
So, we track played around with
various input representations
such as using
regular spectrograms instead
of mel-spectrograms,
that did even worse.
We found that stacking
doesn't help and FastGRNN
only does marginally better
because it has fewer parameters.
So, we have pretty much concluded
that RNNs alone are not
competitive with CNNs,
which is why in
our present exploration,
while we're trying to train
an equivalent student model
from the L3 embedding,
we did not exactly use
vanilla RNN as
our candidate student model,
rather we used a combination
of convolution and recurrence.
So, for knowledge
distillation purposes,
we used a variant of the student
model with convolutions
and another variant with
RNNs as candidate models,
and we trained on
the same UrbanSound 8k.
This is not ideal,
and I'll tell you
why in a second,
but given the time
left in the workshop,
we could only train
on the UrbanSound 8k.
So, this is an example
of this urban model.
We are now learning
from the raw sample.
So, if we're sampling at
48 kilohertz, this is the input.
We are passing it through a layer
of convolution filters, 64,
and then in the CNN variant,
we are passing it
through a bunch of
two de-convolution filters
that vary from two to four.
In the RNN case, we're passing it
through two stack layers,
and again, we're mapping them
to the 10 output classes.
While the CNN does not give
us great accuracy, in fact,
it is comparable with
the accuracy that we
get with the vanilla
RNN approach,
and it also has a fatter model,
which all three of them do.
We are starting to see some
good results with simple GRU,
the GRU variant of simple net.
It is 65 percent accuracy,
and it is staying
pretty constant at
62 percent to 65 percent,
at least in the box that
we have trained so far.
Again, we're competing with
the target of 77 percent,
there is still some gap
to be breached here.
However, we have
trained it on one of
the downstream data sets due to
lack of time this was not ideal,
because the L3 embedding is
really trained from
the big Google data set.
So, one of the first task
that we will do when
we return from the workshop is to
train these existing
student models with
the original Google data that we
were used to train
the L3 embedding,
and we think that we should
be able to get a lot more
out of it at a much smaller size.
The second deduction that
we want to explore
as the next step
is developing
new student architectures
for non speech acoustics sensing.
One of the ideas that we
have been discussing is,
there are some existing
compression techniques
that reduced model size.
For example, through removing
redundancies in the model.
One of them is called deepIOT,
which these two are good
enough compression.
However, it comes with
the cost of accuracy drop,
and we can use that as
a student to buy back
some of their accuracy
drop hopefully
from the original teacher model,
and then once the student
has been fixed,
we can continue further with
modal compression techniques such
as convolution kernel separation,
deep compression
pipeline, et cetera.
In conclusion, we
would like to thank
Microsoft very much for
this opportunity that
they have given us.
It was great to work and
interact with all of you.
Special thanks to
Harsha, Prateek, Aditya,
Professor Monic and Don,
and with that, I thank you all
and open floor to questions.